wie also geht es weiter im Iran und wie
soll Deutschland wie soll der Westen auf
die Proteste reagieren darüber wollen
wir reden mit dem deutsch-iranischen
Schriftsteller David Kermani guten Abend
nach Köln
guten Abend sie haben viele Kontakte in
den Iran in welcher Verfassung befindet
sich das Regime nach sechs Wochen
Protest könnte die Macht der Mullahs
Bröckel nach ihrer Einschätzung
sie bröckelt jedenfalls schon wir wissen
es gibt viele Gerüchte von
absatzbewegungen von familiendienst
Ausland gebracht werden ob das stimmt
das weiß ich nicht da mag auch
Wunschdenken dabei sind aber was wir
sehen ist dass dieser Protest jetzt in
die siebte Woche geht trotz aller Gewalt
trotz des Schießbefehls trotz aller
Ankündigung jetzt sei es endgültig
vorbei die Gäste geweiher nicht die
erste und dennoch geht es immer weiter
und ich möchte es vielleicht mit den
Worten einer ehemaligen
Parlamentsabgeordneten sagen die er
selbst eigentlich zum System gehört
dieser Geist ist nicht mehr in die
Flasche zurück zu bekommen aber klar ist
auch das ist keine Sache von eins zwei
drei vier Wochen das ist wird womöglich
lange dauern das ist ein
waffenstarrendes System es hat eine
Reihe viele gewaltbereite Anhänger die
ihr Leben oder jedenfalls ihr ihre
Zukunft zu verlieren haben und es ist
nicht mehr möglich gleichzeitig mit mit
10.000 100.000 protestieren die Proteste
verstreuen sich ist es ähnlich möchte
man das Beispiel nennen das Kampf gegen
die Apartheid hier haben wir ja auch
eine Geschlechter Apartheid der hat auch
Jahre gedauert und diese Beharrlichkeit
im Inneren und der Druck von außen der
Politik aber auch der
Zivilgesellschaften von außen der hat
dazu geführt dass die Apartheid zu Ende
ging und der wird womöglich auch dazu
führen nur ein solcher Druck kann
womöglich dazu führen dass auch dieses
Regime endlich verschwindet Stichwort
Druck von außen diese Koalition ist ja
angetreten mit dem Ziel eine
feministische eine Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik zu machen wie bewerten Sie
die bisherige Reaktion der
Bundesregierung
ich frag mal zurück Frau Gelenk welcher
Druck wir haben zuerst ein langes
Schweigen gehabt als Proteste als schon
auf Menschen geschossen worden ist auf
insbesondere Frauen dann sagt die
Außenministerin das habe ja gar nichts
mit dem Islam zu tun und dann wurden
unter lauter Getöse lauten getötet
Sanktionen beschlossen die aber rein
symbolisch sind und unser Bundeskanzler
hat bis auf einen einzigen vollkommen
nichtssagenden Tweet in diesen sechs
sieben Wochen kein einziges öffentliches
Wort gesagt zu den Protesten das fällt
auch im internationalen Vergleich auf
nicht Partei zu ergreifen wenn jemand
auf den anderen schießt das ist eine Art
von Partei Name und zwar für den der
schießt der Bundeskanzler mit ihnen die
Bundesregierung vor allem der
Bundeskanzler ergreift mit seinem
Schweigen Partei in diesem Konfliktes
muss ihm das muss uns bewusst sein wir
sind jetzt sozusagen eine Boot mit
Russland mit China mit mit Syrien ich
sehe diese Parteien Name leider nicht
dafür hat der Bundeskanzlerin so
deutlich sagen zu müssen das muss ihnen
nicht leid tun sie sind hier an einem
freien Land der außenpolit Sprecher der
SPD Nils Schmidt hat dafür gesprochen
und der hat dazu aufgerufen dass
atomabkommen am atomabkommen
festzuhalten ist das Realpolitik oder
ein strategischer Fehler
es ist ein realpolitischer Fehler denn
das atomabkommen zielt ja für das hier
übrigens damals das beschlossen wurde
war viele Menschen die mir waren fanden
das gut wir haben sich gefreut aber wir
haben vollkommen veränderte
Rahmenbedingungen vollkommen veränderte
Situation und es ist keine Realpolitik
auf diese vollkommen veränderte
Situation nicht zu reagieren die zu
ignorieren ein solches Abkommen Bedarf
Stabilität die Hoffnung ist ja auch mit
diesen Abkommen dass man
Handelsbeziehungen öffnen kann dass man
das an die Gasabkommen an die
Gasvorkommen im Iran drankommt aber
Handel braucht Stabilität denn Abkommen
doch doch Legitimationen Mindestmaß an
Legitimation und eine ein System das so
offen von seiner Bevölkerung an
praktisch überall im Latten Frage
gestellt wird dass auf seine Menschen
schießen lässt auf Jugendliche schießen
lässt auf Frauen ein solches Regime kann
kein Verhandlungspartner sein und jedes
Abkommen das ist dann irgendwann gäbe
ich kann mir die Bilder gar nicht
ausmalen wieder in so einen Abkommen
gefeiert würde aber ein solches Abkommen
wird auch kein bestand haben weil es von
den eigenen Menschen abgelehnt wird aber
das atomabkommen zielte ja nicht in
erster Linie darauf die Gasvorkommen im
Iran auszubeuten sondern darauf dass die
Atombombe nicht in die Hände des
müller-regimes fällt ist das nicht ein
wichtiges Ziel an dem man festhalten
sollte
wie gesagt das Ziel ist war richtig aus
atomenabkommen hatte zu seiner Zeit
seine Richtigkeit das war ein
wesentliches Ziel nur jetzt ist Iran
sowieso schon sehr sehr nah dran eine
atomabkommen und ist bietet Kalle
keinerlei Gewehr das ist es hat sich
jetzt man sieht es ja unter Ukraine
dieses System bietet keinerlei Gewehr
dafür dass Sie sich an das atomabkommen
hält insofern ist es zwar ein löbliches
Ziel aber das Ziel wird in diesem
atomabkommen nicht erreicht und ich muss
doch drauf bestehen das ist so dass das
atomabkommen natürlich das kann man auch
wirklich überall nachlesen das
atomabkommen natürlich auch
Handelsbeziehungen führt wir Deutschland
insbesondere ist dabei seine
Energiequellen zu diversifizieren das
kann man verstehen nach dem Desaster mit
Russland nur steuern wir auf das nächste
Desaster zu indem wir wieder ein
kurzfristiges energiepolitisches Ziel
voranstellen und dabei übersehen dass
mit diesem Ziel uns überhaupt nicht
gedient ist weil wir das diesen Ziel gar
nicht näher weil der Verhandlungspartner
nicht der ist den wir uns wünschen
david camani war das mit einer
Einschätzung zu dem zu den Verhandlungen
über das atomabkommen die jetzt
ausgesetzt werden sollten vielen Dank
für das Gespräch und einen guten Abend
nach Köln